WELCOME TO TUCKER
WELCOME TO "UCKER
WELCOME TO "TUKER
WELCOME TO "TUCKR
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IT WAS JUST THREE DAYS AGO
THAT "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTERS KELLY AND ROBIN
WERE THE TOAST OF THE LEFT.
BY THINGS MOVE FAST.
THEIR NEW BOOK APPEARED TO
FINISH THE JOB THAT THE
NATIONAL MEDIA STARTED A
YEAR AGO AND TAKE OUT BRETT
KAVANAUGH FOR GOOD.
THE AUTHORS ACCUSE KAVANAUGH
OF COMMITTING A KIND OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AS A COLLEGE
STUDENT MORE THAN 30 YEARS
AGO AT YALE.
DETAILS WERE SPARSE BUT WAS
ENOUGH TO LAUNCH A TSUNAMI
OF RAGE FROM THE LEFT.
SHATTERS ON THE OTHER CABLE
CHANNELS KEY NOUNSED
KAVANAUGH AS A GANG RAPIST.
ALL THE LEADING DEMOCRATS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
DEMANDED THAT KAVANAUGH BE
IMPEACHED AND REMOVED FROM
OFFICE.
AND THEN ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
THE STORY FELL APART.
SUNDAY NIGHT THE NEWSPAPER
WAS FORCED TO MAKE A
DEVASTATING CORRECTION TO
THE PIECE.
IN FACT, THE WOMAN THAT
KAVANAUGH SUPPOSEDLY
ATTACKED DIDN'T REMEMBER
ANYTHING ABOUT THE EVENT.
AND JUST LIKE SO MANY
PREVIOUS STORIES ABOUT BRETT
KAVANAUGH, THE WHOLE THING
TURNED OUT TO BE A CROCK.
SO LAST NIGHT KELLY AND
POGEVIN ON A SHOW HIGHLY
FAMILIAR WITH BOTCHED
STORIES.
THE EXPLANATION DON'T BLAME
US, BLAME OUR EDITORS.
>> WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT
OMISSION THAT THE "TIMES"
LATER FELT BELONGED IN THE
PIECE?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
LAWRENCE, THERE WAS ZERO
INTENT TO MISLEAD ANYBODY
ABOUT THE DETAILS OF THE
INCIDENT.
>> IN YOUR DRAFT OF THE
ARTICLE, DID IT INCLUDE
THOSE WORDS THAT HAVE SINCE
BEEN ADDED TO THE ARTICLE?
>> IT DID.
IT DID.
SO SOMEWHERE IN THE EDITING
PROCESS THOSE WORDS WERE --
>> YEAH, I THINK WHAT
HAPPENED ACTUALLY WAS THAT,
YOU KNOW WE HER NAME AND THE
"TIMES" DOESN'T USUALLY
INCLUDE THE NAME OF THE
VICTIM.
SO I THINK IN THIS CASE THE
EDITORS FELT LIKE PLANE IT
WAS BETTER TO REMOVE IT.
AND IN REMOVING HER NAME,
THEY REMOVED THE OTHER
REFERENCE TO THE FACT THAT
SHE DIDN'T REMEMBER IT.
>> OKAY.
SO, IN THEIR REMOVAL OF THE
NAME, THEY ENDED UP REMOVING
THE WHOLE.
>> I THINK IT WAS EDITING
DONE IN THE HASTE IN THE
EDITING PROCESS AS YOU KNOW.
>> Bret: WELL, ACTUALLY,
THAT STORY COULD BE TRUE.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IS NOT
WHAT IT USED TO BE.
IT'S PERFECTLY BELIEVABLE
THAT SOME HALF ASLEEP
POLITICALLY INFLAMED EDITOR
OF THE PAPER WOULD BLOW ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
STORIES OF THE YEAR.
NOT A VERY IMPRESSIVE NEWS
OUTLET ANYMORE.
BUT A MISSING LINE IS NOT
THE ONLY PROBLEM WITH THIS
STORY.
WATCH THE TREATMENT THE TWO
AUTHORS RECEIVED OF ALL
PLACES ON "THE VIEW."
>> I HEARD THAT THE WOMAN
DIDN'T WANT HER NAME OUT
PUBLICLY.
IF NOT, WHY IS HER NAME IN
THE BOOK?
>> HER NAME IS IN THE BOOK
BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S
RELEVANT INFORMATION.
WE THINK IT'S ACCURATE AND
WE KNOW HER NAME WAS
PROVIDED TO MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE AND THE FBI BY A
WITNESS NAMED MATT STIER WHO
IS A GOOD GOVERNANCE
ACTIVIST IN WASHINGTON WHO
IS A RESPECTED FIGURE AND
HAD PROVIDED THIS NAME.
>> A WERE TOKER CLINTON
LAWYER?
>> HE DID AT ONE POINT, I
UNDERSTAND, DO WORK FOR
WILLIAMS AND CONNOLLY.
>> IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
CREDIBILITY.
>> RIGHT.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S RELEVANT
BACKGROUND.
IN THIS CASE IT WAS VERY
SHORT MENTION AND WE ONLY
TALKED IN BRIEF TERMS ABOUT
WHAT HE IS DOING RIGHT NOW.
SO WE DIDN'T SEE ALL OF THAT
CONTEXT TO BE NECESSARY.
BUT, I UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
ARE BRINGING IT UP AND I
THINK IT'S FAIR.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
JUST A SHORT MENTION.
OF COURSE IT'S THE CRITICAL
CLAIM IN THE STORY/BOOK.
WE LEFT OUT SOME CONTEXT IT.
TURNS OUT SOME PEOPLE THINK
IT'S RELEVANT WHEN A
CHARACTER DESTROYING SMEAR
COMES FROM POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS RATHER THAN FROM,
SAY, ORDINARY CITIZENS.
YOU OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO KNOW
THAT WHEN YOU ARE READING
THE PIECE.
THE "TIMES" DISAGREES
THOUGH.
THEY DON'T THINK YOU DON'T
HAVE A RIGHT TO THAT
CONTEXT.
OF COURSE THESE ARE ALSO THE
PEOPLE WHO TOOK THE TRUMP
DOSSIER SERIOUSLY AND BURIED
THE CONTEXT IN THAT.
YOU KNOW IN SOME WAYS IT'S A
SHAME THAT KELLY AND POGEVIN
BURIED THE BOOK THE BOOK HAS
REVELATIONS IN IT IF TRUE.
THEY WERE THE FIRST OTHERS
TO GET A AN ON THE RECORD
STATEMENT FROM LELAND KEYSER
WHO SUPPOSEDLY COULD
CORROBORATE HER STORY OF
BEING ASSAULTED BUT IN THE
END DID NOT CORROBORATE IT.
WHY DIDN'T SHE?
KEYSER TOLD THE AUTHORS THAT
SHE HAD, QUOTE, NO
CONFIDENCE IN BLASEY FORD'S
STORY.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THE
LEFT WANTS YOU TO HEAR SO,
OF COURSE, THE AUTHORS DOWN
PLAYED THAT AND BURIED IT AT
THE VERY END OF THE BOOK.
REALLY?
SEEMS LIKE THE LEAD BUT, NO,
THEY DOWN PLAYED IT.
THEY ALSO DOWN PLAYED
ANOTHER FACT PATTERN WHICH
IS HOW FAR THE LEFT WAS
WILLING TO GO TO DESTROY
KAVANAUGH LAST YEAR.
MOLLIE HEMMINGWAY AND CARRIE
SEVERINO ALSO WROTE A BOOK
ON THE SUBJECT JUSTICE ON
TRIAL THEY REPORT THAT
LELAND KEYSER FACED
SUSTAINED PRESSURE ON THE
LEFT TO CHANGE HER STORY, TO
LIE AND SUPPORT BLASEY
FORD'S ACCOUNT.
KELLY AND POGREVIN FOUND OUT
WHAT THAT MESSAGE WAS.
THEY GOT TEXT MESSAGES IN
WHICH THEY DISCUSS DEFAMING
LELAND KEYSER A SUBURBAN MOM
OUTSIDE OF D.C. AS A DRUG
ADDICT.
KEYSER CONFIRMED THIS
HAPPENED AS SHE TOLD THE TWO
REPORTERS, QUOTE:  I WAS
TOLD BEHIND THE SCENES THAT
CERTAIN THINGS COULD BE
SPREAD ABOUT ME IF I DIDN'T
COMPLY.
NOW THAT'S AN INTERESTING
STORY.
FORMER RELEVANT UNSUPPORTED
GOSSIP FROM A DECADES OLD
DORM PARTY.
IT JUST HAPPENED LAST YEAR.
THE PROBLEM WITH IT THOUGH
IS THAT THE STORY, THE TRUTH
OF IT MAKES THE ACTIVIST
LEFT LOOK LIKE RUTHLESS
FASCISTS, WHY?
BECAUSE THEY KIND OF ARE.